House Republicans unveil articles of
impeachment against Homeland Security
secretary Alejandro mayorcas GOP leader
saying quote his refusal to obey the law
is not only an offense against the
separation of powers in the Constitution
the US it also threatens our national
security Texas Congressman patf filed
the original article's impeachment
against mayorcas a year ago and joins us
now as the GOP closes in on making it
happen so Congressman for people who say
he just is terrible at his job but it's
not impeachable what do you
say well I say that when you lie under
oath to Congress Brian that that is
impeachable and that's what Eland Marcus
has done not only that but he's violated
the immigration and nationality act um
seven eight times over and these
articles spell that out uh in
specificity uh for instance let me read
you an exact quote myus said under oath
to Congress that the Border was no less
secure than it was previously now if
that's true well let's look at the
numbers in the last two administrations
Obama and Trump that at this point in
their presidencies three years deep they
had about 1.6 million illegal encounters
Joe Biden has 8.5 million that's not
just about like it was before uh we'd
never had a month that we had over
200,000 illegal border crossings we had
20 under Joe Biden and I mean the list
goes on and I could take up the whole
program telling you how uh you know
right how much chaos is on the and it
needs
said you know what's so interesting is
Tom homman worked with him and he says
that he knows better you can't just say
that he's incompetent he says this has
to be intentional do you feel the same
way 100% this is a willful and
systematic refusal to comply with
statutory law I mean and it's there's no
other explanation for it how how in the
world did things explode I mean think
about December was the worst month we'd
ever had 300,000 illegal encounters
under President Trump and fiscal year
2017 we had 300,000 all year so it's You
could argue that this is 12 times worse
than it was before so uh you're going to
go ahead with the Articles of
impeachment you only have a two or three
vote margin do you have every Republican
on board to pass
this right now it looks like there's one
or two Republicans that are wavering so
we should I think it will pass I I
really do because Mark chairman Mark
green my good friend from the homeland
security committee has done an
exceptional job here and you know the
proofs in the pudding aleander marus has
perjured himself he's putting Americans
in danger I mean opioid deaths have
doubled uh under the Biden
Administration and that's hundreds of
thousands of American lives at stake
here so we I think we must go forward
it's our constitutional duty to do so so
you have uh FBI is really concerned
about the Border in fact they came out
and said the threat we call today is new
and unfamiliar in modern history the US
has never suffered an invasion of
Homeland and yet one is unfolding right
now military AG men from across the glob
many from countries or regions not
friendly to the United States are
landing in waves on our soil by the
thousands I mean right there every
American not Republican or Democrat uh
should be concerned with that uh and we
see it every single day that's why you
see the extreme circumstances where the
Texas National Guard is pulling back the
border patrol and says we'll take it
from here and there's been zero
Crossings in uh on Shelby
Park yeah well think about our greatest
geopolitical competitor China a couple
years ago Brian there were only 323
Chinese Nationals that were encountered
on the southern border last year there
were
24,000 so yes this is alarming and it's
Russian Nationals have well have spiked
dramatically we don't even know who
these people are so some some even if 1%
were Sab tours what if China invades
Taiwan and then there's a couple hundred
or 500 Chinese National trained military
men you know committing sabotage and in
an open Society that's not that
difficult
right uh so we have this border bill
that's is uh going to be released I
guess any day now no one's seen the
whole taex outside Senator Langford
Senator Cinema and Senator Murphy and a
representative from the White House I
don't know who it is from what you know
from the highlights you have seen do you
like any part of this bill I think it's
just window dressing I Me Maybe these
Senators want to feel good about
themselves at cocktail parties but you
want to put some real teeth in this
legislation first of all Brian Joe Biden
can fix this today he can fix it right
now he can fix it this morning by simply
reinstituting weight in Mexico which
president Trump so brilliantly did and
if you go down to the border and ask the
agents what's the one thing that could
really stem this tide and mitigate it is
they said just reinstitute wait in
Mexico where your Asylum claim will be
adjudicated while you wait in Mexico but
Joe Biden refuses to do that they're
very eager to sue Texas but they won't
confront the Mexican drug cartels so he
one of the things couple of things that
they do do they say the Asylum claims
will no longer be standing unless you
have proof they said if you just say I'm
under threat that's not going to work
we're going to throw you back right away
you're going to get uh within 6 months
you're going to get a review of your
status they're going to expanded the
expedited deportations uh they're going
to get rid of Catch and Release and they
said there's going to be a threshold of
5,000 that'll be an automatic shutdown
of the Border uh they hope not to get to
5,000 but they said there'll be an
automatic shutdown if they get to that
almost like the stock market when C
there's a certain level of a sell off
those some of those things you can get
on board with right well yeah but the F
yes but the five th000 is ridiculous we
can't normalize 5,000 illegal encounters
every single day if that number was a
thousand then we could talk in fact I
talked to some of the Republican
Senators about that and they also had
grave concerns about that 5,000 number
that's a large number that's a you know
1 15,000 a month that normally back back
a few years ago that would break records
so I definitely don't want to normalize
that that's a horrible part of the
agreement last question just what's the
mechanics is the vote today is the
presentation today what can we expect
oh it'll be this week I I think from
what leadership tells us it'll be this
week and you know what I heck I wanted
to do it a year ago as you mentioned so
I'm glad that it's you know the wheels
of the federal governance grind slowly
but I'm glad we're finally here to this
day and you are grinding uh Congressman
Fallon thanks so much appreciate it
thanks Brian God bless all right I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis